[Музика]
Привіт усім, і настав час англійської,
мене звуть Світлана, і сьогодні у нас
ще один урок про технології,
ви відкриєте дивний, але досить
багатообіцяючий винахід,
ще один є досить корисною технікою,
як ставити запитання  не
допускаючи помилок, і в кінці уроку
ми проведемо вікторину,
іди подивіться на малюнок, що
ви бачите, як ви можете описати цю
картинку, подумайте над відповідями на ці
запитання спочатку, як називаються ці риби
та  чому вони були побудовані з чого
вони зроблені давайте перевіримо це під час
читання тексту скажи ось
питання прочитайте текст і знайдіть
відповіді на ці питання
давайте разом перевіримо так питання номер
один як вони називаються
і чому ви знайшли відповідь
безумовно, це шосейні велосипеди, і вони
названі на честь риби, яка називається щука,
щука, Бахус строкер, і, відповідно,
риба роба Щука друге питання,
чому вони були побудовані, які були
Причини дізнатися про те, як риби
рухаються у воді, чому це
необхідно зробити, щоб створити транспортні засоби,
які здатні рухатися, як риби, і, отже,
економити енергію, щоб вони були створені першими,
щоб дізнатися, як риба рухається
вперед, це означає, що
рухаються через воду  чому для того, щоб
створити транспортний засіб, транспортний засіб – це
Ісаак, то чому нам потрібні ці транспортні засоби,
щоб економно економити енергію,
і вони добре одужують, тому
це була мета створення
цих риб, і питання номер три, з
чого вони зроблені, знайшли відповідь
давайте перевіримо, що вони виготовлені зі скловолокна,
скловолокно гвинт Волох не отримати
нержавіюча сталь нержавіюча сталь почати
Рене прийти сюди ще раз нержавіюча
сталь отримати набір
давайте подивимося на інші слова в
тексті вони виділені жирним шрифтом з вами виміряйте
їх перше слово  робот-робот
, скажімо разом, робот-робот,
хороший робот на кожному коліні робототехніка отримати
другий виготовлений виготовлений
виготовлений набір ми Robli  n ви наступне
слово транспортні засоби транспортні засоби отримати ще раз
транспортні засоби отримати фразу рухатися, як
риба рухатися, як риба рухатися, як риба,
гарна піца Roca так, Reba це
економія енергії економно економить енергію, і вони
тут, щоб економити енергію
Kate дюйми 32 дюйми  Нових дюймів, які ми можемо
отримати, чи можете ви уявити собі цю рибу, приблизно
80 сантиметрів або в дюймах 32 дюйми,
гарна та зроблена зі скловолокна, нержавіюча
сталь, скловолокно, вона зараз глобальна, а
солома з нержавіючої сталі поблизу Яві
добре попрацювала, а тепер перейдемо до
другої частини  нашого уроку це gramma,
і сьогодні ми говоримо про те, як
скласти запитання в пасивному задатку,
щоб отримати пасивний залог,
формула його полягає в тому, щоб бути плюс дієприкметник минулого часу,
але як ви ставите запитання, я поділюся
з
вами  дуже гарна техніка скажіть, що це за
стадіон гарний я називаю цю техніку
дослідження стадіону чи бували ви коли-небудь
на стадіоні, щоб ви знали, як це виглядає,
подивіться на світ велике ігрове
поле посередині праворуч і навколо  це у
нас є кілька доріжок перша доріжка
друга третя комплект і між ігровим
полем і першою доріжкою у нас є
внутрішня крива Браво добре, твоя черга, давайте
намалюємо це, так давайте назвемо це ігрове поле
на бордюрі
Браво перша доріжка, яка у нас є на  дискотека,
друга доріжка та інші готові, це наш
набір для стадіону, він нам знадобиться, щоб
дізнатися слово вода в англійському реченні
на першому треку в англійському
реченні ви можете знайти who або what
предмет у реченні who what the
first track get  у другому треку
завжди запускається мережа, яка має змістовну мережу,
наприклад, я живу, а в наступних треках
ви можете знайти інші слова, я випорожню його,
тому ще раз
на тему першого треку хто або що
вони переходять у мережу та інші частини
речень  це речення із
зупинкою їжі в кінці, якщо ми хочемо поставити
запитання, яке нам знадобиться на узбіччі, де
новий вантажівка білий чи вузький
не більше п'яти сантиметрів, щоб які
слова могли бігти уздовж
бордюру довгі чи короткі  de  скінченно коротко, як-от
what were for is for do come did
ви можете побачити тут на і маленькі дієслова або
модальні дієслова right
вони досить короткі, щоб бігти вздовж
бордюру get давайте подивимося, як це працює, давайте
поставимо запитання чи граєте ви в комп'ютерні
ігри робити  ви граєте написати всі слова
в питаннях є неправильними місцями, але якщо
ми почнемо з цих дієслів, ми отримаємо
запитання так/ні, ви живете так Ajay чи
можуть вони розмовляти так вони можуть
ні вони не можуть писати отримати як задавати інші
запитання вони  називаються поліцейськими
питання хто що чому коли де як
правильно для них є ігрове поле
що давайте поставимо питання що ти
зараз робиш що ти зараз робиш
дивишся урок саме коли ти
ходив до школи минулого разу коли ходив
до  школа
nice де поставте своє запитання з де не
забудьте взяти по одному слову з кожної
колонки готове ще одне запитання
де добре де ви залишите
найпростіше право більше з чому чому птахи
літають хто ким ви граєте в комп'ютерні
ігри з ким  ви граєте в комп'ютерні
ігри з одним словом, як і
іншими, які поєднуються з як
часто, скільки часу, скільки щось правильно,
тож давайте спробуємо, як ви потрапите до школи,
як ви дістанетеся до школи, усі ці
питання є активними, тому що ми
запитав про вас хто, але сьогодні ми
навчимося ставити запитання в
пасивному стані, і ми знаємо, що в пасивному
задатку ось який об'єкт,
давайте заберемо цю картинку, так чому
ці дієслова залишилися зверніть на них увагу
: are was were do you  пам'ятайте про них,
що це форми дієслова to be, і
ви знаєте пасивний залог to be плюс дієприкметник минулого,
тож дієслово to be у
своїх формах буде тут перед
підметом і дієприкметником минулого
часу з Еді або третьою формою
правильно, давайте подивимося, коли було щось я
роблю телефон винайшов це давайте скажемо це
швидше коли був винайдений телефон
це
чому був винайдений robo pyke чому був винайдений robo
pyke подивіться на ці
запитання перше запитання що таке
вони холодні правильно Кейт друге питання,
чому вони були створені, все
добре,
а третє, що вони складені,
тому структура питання в
пасивному пасиві спочатку йде питальне слово, а
потім дієслово to be у правильній формі, саме
тут це
ван Гог  what і земляна частка
давайте перевіримо, наскільки добре ви можете це зробити,
що є відповіддю на запитання, яке ви
повинні зробити, помістіть ці слова у
відповідну воду. Згадайте про стадіон
готовий.
Давайте перевіримо, де вони були виготовлені,
де вони були виготовлені, і
відповідь знаходиться на  Массачусетський
технологічний інститут ще одне речення, а тепер
відповідь полягає в тому, що студенти складають
питання, тому хто їх виготовив.
Дещо заплутано, чому я
поділюся з вами ще одним секретом, дуже
легко дізнатися лише одне запитання
про виконавця в  пасивне це питання:
ким була Америка відкрита, скажімо
разом, ким була Америка,
швидше була відкрита, ким була Америка, була відкрита ким
була Америка di  швидше
виявив, хто була Америкою, ще раз
відкрив, хто була Америкою, але давайте
додамо інтонацію, ким була Америка, яку
відкрили ок, що це дає нам
, це питання -
до речі, хто був Америкою,
ви все ще
точно пам’ятайте Христофора Колумба правильно,
тож якщо ви хочете знати, хто щось зробив,
але в пасивному стані так, це означає, що ми
повинні запитати Como bola для Америки
Ріта, і я хочу показати, що це
не до крему, як ви ставите
такі запитання
подивіться замість America, ми можемо
поставити будь-яке інше слово, наприклад назва
винаходів, і ось дієслово у причастій минулому,
наприклад, who was that
telefilm invented by who was the
phone
invented by чи пам’ятаєте відповідь
на це запитання з нашого першого  урок
хороший Олександра Грема Белла. Правильно,
це структура питання -
виконавець про виконавця, але в пасивній
практиці більше запитань у
пасивному, давайте використовувати thi  Зірка запитання вправи
в середині ми поставимо або причастя минулого,
або назву деяких
винаходів, і давайте поставимо запитання,
які починаються з цих слів, до речі,
де їхнє місце на нашому стадіоні Хара
на ігровому полі, дізнайся, який
ми винахід  запитуючи про нехай це буде
готовий набір для 3D-друку давайте разом поставимо перше
запитання, коли
далі буде винайдений набір для 3D-друку, скажімо
разом і швидше, коли був винайдений 3D-друк,
отримаємо ще одне запитання: де
давайте це зробимо разом,
де був винайдений 3D-друк, скажімо
це швидше, коли був винайдений 3D-друк,
отримати наступне, як та сама структура, скажіть
це на вашу
користь давайте скажемо разом, як був винайдений 3D-
друк, добре попрацював далі
чому один хороший разом
чому був винайдений 3d-друк, дізнайтеся, кого
ви пам'ятаєте про Америку як  щоб запитати,
скажіть це самостійно, давайте скажемо
разом, хто був винайдений 3D-друком
, ще раз хто був винайдений 3D-друком
, ммм-хм з міжнародним, хто
був 3D-друком  друк винайдено get what або
ми можемо запитати, що для
Navi show, то для чого був винайдений 3d-друк
ще раз,
навіщо був винайдений 3D-друк,
тепер давайте трохи змінимо це, тому що ми
запитуємо про вакцини, але безглузді вакцини
це окреме чи  множина один або багато так
множина це означає, що ми будемо використовувати not was
але ми маємо рацію, але структура та
сама, тому давайте почнемо говорити повільно
перше питання, коли були винайдені вакцини,
коли були винайдені вакцини, ви
chun-kit
хочете, щоб вакцини винайшли правильно
наступний ми повернулися з моменту
винайдено добре як як вакцини винайшли
ворота чому чому ми повернулися з моменту винайдено
добре
ой ми повернулися відколи вигадав
ще раз це питання хто робить ставку
винаходить супер, а останній чому
можливо, впевнені, що винайшли вакцини від шерсті,
для чого винайшли вакцини.
Гарний час для, будь ласка, подивіться, що
ми перші, ви можете побачити дієслова в
дужках, це значущі дієслова,
правильно поставте їх у ei  er третя форма або
edie, щоб зробити причастий час минулого і
знайти відповідне місце у питанні,
насправді, поставте ці запитання,
давайте разом вирішуємо перше запитання,
на честь кого назвав космічний телескоп Хаббл чи пам’ятаєте ви
структуру запитання,
хто пише що й називає, але як минуле
причастка що питання
гарне давайте скажемо разом,
хто такий космічний телескоп Хаббл, названий на
честь матраца круто нас гроші скажімо
телескоп гарна робота
зробіть решту самостійно поставте запитання
[Музика]
давайте перевіримо ваші запитання, хто такий
космічний телескоп Хаббл, названий на честь
Нійса  по-друге, які країни виробляють найбільше
комп’ютерів у третій, хто був
заснований Microsoft на даний момент до того, що
Nintendo знайшла після 1900 року,
і останньою був телефон Apple,
вперше випущений для мене Бушем,
але тост – це відповісти на запитання
своїми  власні ідеї правильно, що ви
пам'ятаєте, якщо не знаєте приблизно,
робіть прогнози, і ви зараз добре перевірите,
ось відповіді bu  t завдання полягає в тому, щоб
зіставити запитання з відповідями,
знайти правильну відповідь на ці запитання,
виконано, давайте перевіримо, тому давайте прочитаємо
запитання та відповімо першим, на кого є
космічний телескоп Хаббл, названий на честь американського
астронома Едвіна Хаббла. Хороше запитання
номер два, в яких країнах найбільше
комп’ютерів  Зроблено в Китаї та Тайвані
питання номер третє,
як була заснована Microsoft Біллом
Гейтсом і Полом Алленом. Зараз номер четвертий
був Nintendo, заснований після
1900 року, тепер у вісімдесят вісімдесят дев'ятому, а
номер п'ять був Apple iPhone,
вперше випущений у 2007 році  щоб
отримати домашнє завдання подивіться, ваше
домашнє завдання – створити власну вікторину про
світ високих технологій, не забудьте використовувати
пасивний пасив, а потім запросіть свою сім’ю та
друзів взяти участь у вашій вікторині, чи
подобається вам домашнє завдання, так думайте і
вау,  баланс перемога наш урок закінчився
дякую за вашу активну роботу і слідкуйте за
оновленнями та до скорої зустрічі
[Музика]
ви